the diversity and the range of Flemish
patterns and colors and forms of the
chickens are just fascinating you really
got to like it kinda dusty dirty noisy
very noisy but it's sort of fun and
gratifying in this way I'm Tom whiting
owner and founder of whiting farms in
Delta Colorado
a poultry genetics and production
company that specializes in fly tying
feathers for reasons I can't even
remember why I started raising poultry
when it's about ten years of age and I
just never cease to find in an
interesting subject I'm sure most people
think they know what feathers are really
feathers are highly specialized
elongated reptilian scale it's just
evolved into feathers a major function
is sexual selection meaning that the
roosters have very brilliant and very
showy feathers so the rooster with the
finest feathers might get the most hens
and those feather trade get increased
over time it takes almost a year to grow
the Roosters from baby chicks
I think we've settled in the 80,000
rings at any one time chickens because
they're small and they reproduce very
quickly we can radically alter how the
birds would grow their feathers it's
amazing how much with selection the
birds can have their feathers change
over time some generations so it's going
to Colorado Salt Lake City Massachusetts
Sweden Germany Norway way of Denmark
Kenya this whole order right here I know
is going waiting to go to Japan
rooster feathers are used in tying
fishing flies or they have been for
hundreds of years we know because there
are defensive feather so they have some
rigidity to them that rest on the
surface tension of the water and it
looks like an insect to the fish and the
fish will see it and the dimples it
makes in the water and they'll want to
strike that and that's the way the
fisherman catches the fish one of the
reasons I'm in this business is I like
just dealing with the birds I find them
endlessly fascinating and my favorite
time of day is often when I'm going out
through the birds on a daily basis and
looking at them seeing how they're doing
and I feel like I know them intimately
and I handle every bird in the system
I've seen the trajectory or the arc of
where the feathers have come from but I
don't view this as something that I'm
doing it's rather I'm doing it for a
while and I feel a responsibility to
cultivate them in a responsible way
protecting from diseases so they don't
get wiped out and so they will be
available for as long as people want to
tie fishing flies
[Music]